and the oddsmakers have installed
devonta smith
the favorite to be the player out eagles
take again they're currently
at number 12 plus 170 the guy for the
eagles and that would mean that devonta
smith isn't a top 10 pick or a top 11
pick as the case may be
unless the eagles do trade up and
there's some chatter that maybe they
would try to do that
smith measured six feet 166
at the indianapolis medical check there
wasn't a scouting combine this year
but 125 to 150 players went to
indianapolis to get checked out
physically
smith had that badly injured finger in
the national championship game
six foot 166 at his pro day he said he
was 170 he was listed by alabama as
6-1-175 we know how that goes though
we we know that you never can trust the
numbers that are officially listed by
any team
regarding a player's height or weight
but six foot 166
dusts off the concern that he's too
small
i i we've talked about this multiple
times does it matter at all chris
not really i think it more it matters
more politically than it does
actually on the field like again
you'd get in i'd be concerned if i saw
166
and there was a lot of film and evidence
in the sec
with the best corners in all of college
football
and again he's practicing against really
great corners and a top 10 pick in
patrick certain every day
but i'd be worried if i saw evidence on
film to go
hey this guy's got some strength or you
know
he's a little frail there's issues here
you know i
then i'd be worried i would now i know
the nfl is a different game and it is
there's no doubt about it i don't care
if you're at alabama lsu ohio state
i was at texas when we were you know one
of the best teams in football
hey it ain't it ain't the nfl the nfl is
a different animal as far as
physicality the smartness of the players
quickness and how things happen so going
over the middle in the nfl is going to
be different than going over the middle
again in the
the rose bowl against notre dame or the
national championship game against ohio
state so it is different that way
where i say politically mike it matters
is this
and this is where i think like if you're
jamar chase or devante smith ooh they're
so both so good what do we do what do we
do
jamar chase is gonna win the battle now
for sure in my eyes because of that
number a little bit
because what it is gonna scare people
away from is just
if he does get hurt right oh he he got
hurt in year one or year two because he
is frail and he's been banged up
you're gonna hear it from everybody well
you drafted a 166 pound receiver what
did you think was going to happen
all these people had these concerns
before the draft and i think that's
where it maybe
affects him a little bit ultimately i
don't think it's a drop or anything like
that in the draft
but i think it's going to just make
people question and be a little scared
that way
what would be the number how light would
he have to be to get you to say just
that number itself
is a concern yeah would you have to dip
under 160 yeah i would say so
i mean listen i don't love the way that
number looks right there
i don't you know but but here's the
balance too
right like if you were in the 150s yeah
i'd be like man i don't know i don't
think i can do that
i don't think i i really don't but like
you know here's the here's the other
avenue or issue that you have here the
guy is special
all right he can fly he's the best route
runner in the draft
he's awesome in so many areas you know
but
but i think i think the um
the uh what was i gonna say here i
totally just lost my train of thought
um that's all right we're not live we're
on tape man no big deal i
i know i what what is that where was i
about to go with that let me let me well
oh yeah the adding the weight
sorry yeah sorry the adding the weight
you know that could affect his speed
that's where it's a tough
really challenge for guys like devonta
smith and obama's quarterback
i'm sitting there going wait you're 166
and you run 432
or you can be 176 or in 180
and what run four four five i'd go
devonte screw that
extra 10 pounds let's just let's run 4-3
and you continue to work on your
techniques and your quickness and all
that
so we can just keep throwing 60-yard
bombs and scoring touchdowns
and that's the other issue for a guy
like him that he's got a balance about
you know
going all in on the weight thing i also
wonder look he
i wonder if he resisted getting on the
scale when he went to indianapolis
i know because he has been very coy
about his weight he has
and even though it's a non-issue from a
football standpoint it is an issue
politically as you said it could be the
thing that
causes a team to skew one way over the
other because they don't want to get
that i told you so i told you so i told
you so
down the line i just wonder whether he
considered saying no i'm good you know
when you're in there and you submit to
the process
you go to see the doctor what do they do
they tell you to get on the scale and i
know sometimes like i really don't want
to get on the scale i
ate too much pizza this weekend but um
you know i
i i know i also wonder if he knew he was
going to be weighed
i wonder that because that's the first
thing i thought of he could have eaten a
whole pizza before he walked into the
doctor's office right
you chugga you have a gallon of water in
your hand you know
that that's that's that's what you do
you're right you do something just to
fake it for that moment i bet you he
didn't expect to be weighed in
i i that would be my money but um yeah
we'll see
again i still think this is a guy that
has a very good chance of going top ten
i certainly think it'll be top 15
there's no way he falls far
farther than that and really i mean
really mike
if atlanta goes pits right and then
if cincinnati somehow goes jamar
chase right which i don't think is crazy
i don't think it's crazy there penny
stool jamar chase or whatever tackle
they like
there could be some play for devonta
smith i wouldn't be shocked if he was
sitting there at seven
eight nine and somebody made him made a
move to come up and get him he he's
pretty damn special i'll be interested
to see if that scenario happens
will the lions take a receiver at seven
mike i mean there's no gallaudet there's
no marvin jones there's really nothing
they have at that position on their
roster that's special right now
would they do that are they going to
trade down i don't know but devonte
smith isn't intriguing as far as
you know where or what happens to him in
this top 15.
well as it relates to the lines i'll
tell you this if he only weighs 166 he
hasn't been biting many kneecaps or if
he has been he's spitting them out and
not chewing them up and swallowing
he needs to be eating some kneecaps and
other body parts to get over 170.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports